not only was played a surprise hit for
Marvel its influence can still be found
in some unexpected places to honor that
legacy we're looking at how blade
changed superhero movies even if he
didn't always notice Marvel characters
have been hits on television since a
Marvel Super Heroes cartoon debuted in
1966 the film success came much harder
the first feature based on a Marvel
comic was an infamous 1986 flop Howard
the Duck and things somehow went
downhill from there with the Punisher
and Captain America both turned into
low-budget disasters it's enough to make
any comic book fan sick
would you please pull over the car I am
going to get sick
okay all right that changed in the 90s
though thanks to blade which became a
certified hit earning over 70 million
dollars at the domestic box office
Marvel itself however saw very little
benefit from this financial boom
struggling to emerge from bankruptcy in
the late 90s Marvel only pocketed a
measly 25,000 from blade success but
even that had a silver lining
after earning so little from blade and
other films like x-men and spider-man
Marvel decided to make their own film
production company in order to retain
all the profits from their characters
the result was a Marvel Cinematic
Universe which may never have existed
without blade writer David s Goyer has
been behind some of the biggest
superhero films ever with writing
credits on the entire Dark Knight
trilogy Man of Steel and Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice but he may
never have had the chance to do these
films if not for blade IRA a script
called blade and that script changed my
career completely the first time I wrote
a script without any editorial
interference it works and Goya went on
to write all three films in the Blade
trilogy even directing the final
installments played Trinity take a look
at this
you gotta be kidding me
gloomy vibes night creatures black
leather goth was big in the 1980s but by
the 90s casual crunch styles hip hop
culture and bright pop colors ruled the
day until blade that is blade helped
usher in a new wave of dark affair with
a sleek cinematic style that informed
both superhero films on Hollywood in
general one doesn't need heightened
senses to notice the direct line from
blade to the zombie action of Resident
Evil or the vampire versus werewolf
battles of the underworld franchise even
the matrix follows in Snipes
leather-clad footsteps both in its shiny
black aesthetic and in his ideas of an
underworld waging a war that humans
can't say the tagline for the 1978
Superman movie starring Christopher
Reeve boldly declared you'll believe a
man can fly we did but it also helps
that everybody in the entire world
already knew who Superman was and the
same was true of the 1989 mega hit
Batman I want you to tell all your
friends about me
and that man with other comic book films
floundering conventional wisdom and
Hollywood was only the biggest and most
famous superheroes to be successful at
the box office they changed all that
an obscure cult character even among
comic book fans the success of the film
proved that even seedless superheroes
could be box-office gold if the films
were damn right so if you liked
guardians of the galaxy or Doctor
Strange
you can thank played for blazing the
trail Hollywood also had another bit of
conventional wisdom that proved to be a
bunch of crap the idea that comic book
movies were for kids sure Tim Burton's
Batman had a darker aesthetic but even
that quickly made way for nipple suits
and bad puns what killed the dinosaurs
yes comic book fans though knew that
there was a lot more depth in the source
material there's a reason DC had to
start putting a mature readers label on
their comics and the late 80s but until
blade the film world felt that comic
book movies were just silly stuff for
kids you want to go there mine
blade brought a darker more grounded
sense of realism and violence the comic
book films it was the first character
from the big two publishers Marvel and
DC to arrive in American theatres with
an out rating and its success paved the
way not only for more serious superhero
treatment and mainstream film but also
for a wave of our rated comic book films
from Sin City to Deadpool to Logan even
Marvel's Netflix shows Oh bladed debts
look again at Daredevils hard-hitting
punches and you might spot a resemblance
the blades blood-sucking melees Thank
You blade check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite films are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]